on uh what what we're doing now is uh
making sure that we support people
through tough times and lives i i've
said we would so uh it's a it's a it's a
big bazooka it's it's uh twelve hundred
pounds for eight million homes across
the country uh 300 pounds extra for
pensioners who are entitled to cold
weather payments uh another 150 pounds
for people uh or who are on disability
benefit and
um of course putting more money
into local government to help uh
families who are finding things
particularly tough i'm not gonna pretend
that this is gonna fix everything for
everybody uh immediately and there are
still gonna be pressures but it's a very
very substantial commitment by the
government to getting us through what
will be i'm afraid still uh bumpy time
with the increase in in energy prices
around the world and respect
what i think it will also uh help to do
is just get us through until uh i
believe that prices will start to abate
and uh we'll be in a much much stronger
position the reason we're gonna be in a
strong position is because we have so
many people uh in work uh helping us to
uh giving us the tax base we need to
look after everybody else in terms of
a high employment economy that we want
in terms of some of those figures prime
minister are you worried that spending
10 billion more than you are going to
raise from the windfall tax levy may be
inflationary well we've looked at that
very carefully and i think that the
answer to that is no because
i i don't think that it will lead to
necessary to more uh discretionary
spending simply because uh people's
outgoings are going to uh
go up and have have been going up
already as a result of the
of the of the increased cost of energy
and food so it's intended to help to
match the needs of people uh right now
we can do it because we're in a strong
economic position we've got uh loads of
people uh in work earning we've got
unemployment at the lowest level uh
since 1974 which i don't think people
would have predicted uh when we went
into uh de covid into the into all those
lockdowns and
it's
what we're really dealing with is the
aftershocks of kobe the economic
aftershocks of kobe spiking energy
prices we've got to get through it we're
using our fiscal firepower to do it and
then we'll come up much stronger the
other side what's the difference then
between the labour party and the
conservative party on tax and spend
very simple so when it comes to
the
[Music]
this particular policy uh what it does
for instance is it uh it's much more
it's much more generous uh this this
gives 1200 pounds for every uh for
eight million households uh but what it
also does is it is the uh the levy is
designed
so that uh companies can offset uh
investments that they're making in new
energy supply or in green technology to
the tune of 91p uh in the pond and so
what we want to and this is what i kept
i've been saying for months and months
they've been listening carefully to my
answers uh we want to have a solution
that that protects people but also uh
protects investment in our economy
because
as we come through this the way to fix
the problem of of inflation in energy
prices is also to have more sustainable
energy plus a supply in in the uk and
that's why we're moving to 50 gigawatts
of wind 25 gigawatts of
of nuclear and all the other investments
that we're making but we we need the
private companies to do the same you
mentioned the raft of help announced by
the chancellor yesterday um
that is a temporary measure as he said
uh one-off payments
how is that going to help families who
are struggling long-term because really
it's a sticking plaster isn't it we've
got to do some stuff that is timely it's
the right time to do it
it's targeted at the people in it so so
three quarters of the of the homes that
uh will will benefit uh will be those
who are the most uh the most vulnerable
uh
it
overall uh about uh a third of the of
the of the households in in the uk
will benefit from from what we're doing
so it's a it's it's a temporary thing
because after what you want you don't
want what you want is the natural
strength of the economy and uh the
people's uh people's wages people's
employment to be continuing to power us
forward and and that will happen
but what you need to do is is help
people to cope now with the particular
spike in energy prices that that off gem
uh uh
predicted the other day
you say you've helped people now but
there's an argument isn't there because
a degree of families aren't going to
need this help there are some people who
will get it with two households or get
it more than one so
isn't this a policy which benefits
people who are already wealthy at the
expense of the taxpayer no that i just i
just said that the overwhelming majority
of the homes uh the households that will
benefit are those that are uh are most
vulnerable they'll be lost potentially
this is massively massively uh redis
redistributive uh you should look at
what uh the the ifs and others have had
to say about all the or the uh the
resolution foundation this is a
massively redistributive positive it's
the right thing to do you know people uh
talking to the right thing to do prime
minister the chancellor yesterday said
respectfully the chancellor said
yesterday he would donate his 400 pounds
to charity will you do the same i i
think it's uh well my arrangements are a
different because i i live in a
government flat but uh i think it's it's
important that uh the
um
people
should recognize that these these
payments uh will will not
uh necessarily cover the
the increased cost fully i mean you know
that what we can't cover every single
cost that people are going to face we've
got to be we've got to be realistic
about that
and
um
however
they will go a long way towards helping
people uh moving on slightly prime
minister uh four more of your mps have
called for your resignation since the
publication of the su-grey report are
you confident you've got enough backing
within your party to to survive i i
yes but i think i gave uh some some
pretty some pretty vintage and
exhaustive answers uh on all that
subject uh the other day in the in the
house of commons uh and then in a
subsequent uh press conference and and
we really gave that you were aware of
what was happening why why did you
tolerate the culture prime minister that
was happening at that time i i think if
you if you if you look at the uh the
answers i gave in the house of commons
over over more than
over more than two hours i think you
will be you don't feel people deserve to
hear it from you here in person i think
you'll be able to
to see i i answered that very very
extensively and then indeed uh
subsequently to representatives from
your organization uh in a further press
conference later on and what i also said
uh was that uh we're at what we want to
do is is focus on driving jobs uh
driving uh investment in this country
and what we're doing today uh is we're
talking about getting people off welfare
and and into work and we can see that
and just just quickly just quickly
prime minister one of the most sure one
of the most remarkable things about uh
about what's happening today uh is that
we've got uh we're helping people into
into gigabit broadband but we've got
347 000 people off welfare and into work
thanks to the the way to work scheme
that we said premise i've got an
important question here in the northeast
one of our viewers called mark who lives
in county durham he contacted us he's
struggling with his bills with his
energy bills and he
is currently as we speak at a car boot
sale selling possessions to help him get
through to the end of the month
what can you say to people to mark and
to people like him who are really on the
bones so so to to mark and everybody and
i i let me say first of all i know how
tough it it feels for people and i know
uh and it will cont i can't pretend mark
that we're going to fix everything uh
but we can certainly help and so for
people like mark what we're what we're
doing and for people who are facing
particular hardship uh what we're doing
is we're giving in addition to
everything i i just said so there's a
1200 pounds to uh to 8 million we do
know this prime minister respectfully if
you're continuing to do more and people
are continuing to struggle
we need more that's right so what we're
also doing is another
500 uh million pounds uh to local
councils uh to help people like mark who
are facing particular hardship now i'm
not getting so my message to mark is
we're going to help you in any way that
we can we can't fix everything we can't
we we shouldn't we should not pretend
that we can
but what we will do is make sure that we
are in an economically robust position
so that we have uh people in in
high-wage high-skill jobs uh as as we go
forward and we continue to invest in in
infrastructure continue to invest in
skills continue to invest in in
technology and that is the best
long-term solution you had phenomenal
success here in 2019 across parts of the
northeast however brexit has been pushed
through cost of living crisis is biting
your popularity has taken a hit in the
polls um do you feel this is an area
that is slipping away from you
my job is not to give any kind of
running commentary on politics i have to
i have to get on and deliver for the
people in this country and that was a
great respect for what we